I'm gonna start with a kind of general
question for everybody for all the teams
okay and this is just some general kind
of stuff I want to ask a kind of series
of questions and I'll work my way
through each group so let's let's start
with Vincent and Darren and to begin
with I want to ask about briefly about
your backgrounds I kind of you know you
used to make terrible films like as a
kid my dad super 8 millimeter camera I
cast my parents in various roles and
they did it because they had to then I
started doing drama as a kid again and
I'd you know use actors for my drama
quest to make films and then I went to
film school after that I realized it was
pretty hard to actually get paid to
direct so then I am I've been producing
for a lot with Darren but I've also been
working in casting for a like a long
time and I work as an agent for child
actors and I'm by doing that it's it's
been really great practice to learn
effective ways to direct actors I think
so there was a bit of a gap in my
directing career and then I really
wanted to get back and direct but the
more I was producing the more people
just so me as a producer and I was
wanted to get back and direct so so this
was the project there was a there was a
gap and I ended up just putting all of
my own money into into making it good
excellent Darren you want to say
something brief well like Vincent from a
young age I was sort of doing plays and
things like that at home but I was
always very creative I achieved a patent
at a very young age of 18 years of age
and actually for a recycling system for
a company's brief
[Laughter]
and then actually I moved in to because
I was young and it was back in the early
90s I moved into the internet and became
a sort of a dot-com entrepreneur and
then of course the internet moved in the
direction of filum with the likes of
Netflix and I just happened to move in
that direction doing some advertising
for the likes of Middleton and Jemison
and then music videos for universal and
and likes and myself and Vincent started
working on together on those projects
and then eventually M films so yeah okay
alright yeah and I'm gonna give you guys
some very quick questions then we'll
work our way down the whole line how
many days did you shoot I said we did
six days initially with the the actors
in Dublin which which looks a lot like
Liverpool and and then we went to
Liverpool and shot on the actual
locations we did two days there where we
filmed the exteriors of the shopping
centre the police stations and and all
done very little change so it kind of
feels like it's all set in Liverpool and
it's authentic very good and now can I
ask what your budget was yeah I kept
going off that that's something we're
all familiar with I mean we ended up
around like maybe 35,000 or something
and then eight dollars or pounds or
euros you're right so it's a little more
about yeah but then you don't really
budget for film festival fees and all of
that like afterwards so so it's still
going up right very good and how was it
financed you said earlier you kind of
put your own money into it pretty much I
did yeah because it's a it's it's such a
sensitive subject you know um you know
people would have been they were afraid
to kind of put funding into it because
it had the potential to be you know an
extremely divisive film or or else just
made in supremely bad taste
I hope it's neither but yes so in the
end I I got a bit frustrated and figured
the only way it was gonna get made was
if I was if I emptied my entire bank
account into it and hid the credit cards
heart and you did I
it was crazy yeah great piece of work
alright look let me jump to Jeremy and
Maria same questions but very brief on
the background because really what I'm
driving at is this and the Student
Academy Awards we have Europeans
sometimes that do very well and although
their film students they're about 35 and
they're directing BMW commercials so
they're very experienced in the Student
Academy Awards sometimes on the foreign
films so I'm looking for that kind of a
really brief background well actually I
grew up in the countryside I always been
a dream to be a filmmaker and I start
doing skateboard videos it led me to do
documentaries I traveled the world I
studied at film school and I always just
wanted to do fiction film so this my
second short fiction film great I do
want to say something about all the
directors that are that are next to me
right now and that is all of them have
made other shorts and all of them wrote
these films one was a co-writer but all
of them wrote their films so that's what
have started except from skin that was
chlorite written by Chiron okay good
there right right right but then you you
co-wrote it but we'll get down to in a
second so a Maria
question number two how many shoot days
five days five days total very good and
what was the budget
it was dollars in damage right 150,000
yeah very good
and how was it financed we were lucky
enough to get grants from the govern in
Quebec so from so deck and calc so
that's where the bulk of the of the
financier teams yeah right we're gonna
come back to everybody so everyone will
have a chance to talk again Marguerite
yes Mary Ellen and
I'm sorry for Marianne and Marie Allen
background background I have been an
actress for over 20 years and I also
produce and this is my second short film
and we we started working on this a
couple years ago we've been friends for
a long time and yeah and that's it
excellent and how many shoot days three
Wow
and the budget Canadian Canadian which
is like 22,000 not not really it's
probably 150 wouldn't it be yes yeah I
was kidding okay and and and how was it
financed so the same as full of Canadian
the Quebec and Canadian governments so
tax credits and so that can calc
excellent yeah you know the the the
non-us filmmakers get a lot of
government support we don't we don't get
that here we're very fortunate hard to
get yeah yeah and jumping ahead to skin
guy tell us a little bit about your
background our break ground is like your
husband and wife I knew that but I'm
glad you told them buddy yes I started
Tel Aviv Israel and we had a
long-distance relationship in a way and
I moved to the States
I made films in Israel features and
shorts and when I moved to the States
this was our first kind of a project
together that launched into the feature
called skin said right like a short
before the feature right because because
if anybody who doesn't know skin was the
short was picked up by Fox Searchlight
and this team has already made a feature
out of skin but in reading the synopsis
that seemed a little different but of
course it's not 12 minutes long so it
has to be so it's a it's a little
different and fuller story
how many shoot days four and a half Wow
and the budget
I don't know if I want to say because we
can we as you did because of the flock
searchlight situation no no no they just
came in at the very end to help us with
this sort of but no we emptied our
retirement fund into this so that that
answers my last question you guys again
basically financed it yourself we so we
wanted we had a full script for the
feature the features based on a true
story and no one back in 2016 early 60s
I wanted to make a film about you know
the alter right you know the white
supremacist movie in this country
because they felt that it wasn't sort of
a big deal until Trump got it yeah in
charlottesville and I so we we decided
guy and Sharon wrote this script and we
just said [ __ ] it let's just make our
own project and and right after we made
the short the the feature got financed
and and we premiered at Toronto and
we're coming out in July yeah excellent
thanks all right I'm gonna jump to
another question again for everybody the
films for the most part except for
Marguerite I have to hasten to add our
dark and and very moody and in in
thinking about this I have to say that I
have seen certain trends in the past
kind of influenced artists and kind of
take over I think there's a certain if
you will kind of zeitgeist right now
amongst artists that I don't want to
talk too much about but I'd like to ask
our filmmakers to talk about it so maybe
we'll start this time with with the guy
and and Jamie and ask you to react to
that situation you know I'm I'm coming
from a troubled country with a lot of
racism a lot of troubles to it trouble
country and I think that the movies are
reflection of what we're experienced
right now in the world the world is dark
we see it in France
and when Jews are being attacked we just
came back from Berlin from festival when
we saw the right-wing you know I was
raising and and and people skinheads in
the streets and you know both my
grandparents are Holocaust survivors and
seeing this influence you immediately
now la in New York are bubbles in a way
but drive two hours away from LA and you
start to see Confederate flags all over
the place and you know the states is in
a very dark place right now so I think
it's a sheer reflexion for all of us
filmmakers of what's going on in the
world and it's you know it's it happen
after Vietnam is so like you know the
deer hunter and all those movies and you
thought after every every dark time
there's this expression from from cinema
and we have a five month old daughter
and and so I think it was a lot on our
minds what is this next generation
inheriting how does how do these
mentalities affect children then they
become adults and they have children and
so how does it perpetuate generation to
generation so I think we're we're scared
and and that was why we felt very
compelled to make this Mary Ellen and
and Mary Ann I think Marguerite is is a
kind of respite tonight but tell us how
you feel about the collection and and in
this issue well I can I can talk about
Marguerite I think I understand where
all these filmmakers come from I wanted
to make Marguerite because there is so
much violence in the world it was my way
of saying you know the only thing that
can counter that is human connection
it's compassion it's empathy so that's
really that was my motivation for making
Marguerite so I think it's just a
different point of view on the same
subject it's maybe a more feminine point
of view and I'm the only female felt
filmmaker so I can say that but but yeah
I mean I'm really moved by these films I
wouldn't watch them ten times in a
rogue's I I would die I think I'm like
still shaking but but it's true I mean
everything that we saw on screen is is
real and and scary
something and Jeremy and Maria Garcia
your turn
yeah well I guess we've been traveling
to festivals this year and it's been
such different films that we saw you
know there's a lot of communities and
stuff so but I feel from from my
perspective for full it came from a
nightmare when I was a little boy and it
came also from my relationship with my
best friend at a time where we used to
pull pranks at each other and this kind
of toxic mess community that like as
boys you know it we can push ourselves
to do to to trade dangerous stuff to go
a bit too far so that's really a
reflection of of what I saw as a child I
think that it goes a bit what everybody
said we're like it's very personal film
this V comes from such a true place and
it really happened that tonight is a
selection of impact is darker films but
for my phone specifically I really
wanted the ending to be hopeful because
at the end of the day I think everything
is full circle and you know sometimes
nature speaks to you and so I wanted to
have this kind of almost a very lyrical
moment that kind of leaves you it open
yeah no I think like having hope in a
film like where darkness is there's also
hope in something better and I feel like
also there's so many films but the way
that I can perceive the selection of
tonight is like they're all impactful
film in the way they're made and what
they're bringing to the table more than
darker or lighter film so I feel like
maybe that's where people were really
interested by those films in particular
very good and Vincent and Darren your
last well a bit a bit like faux like we
experienced we were young and when those
boys actually committed that atrocity we
were only a few years older than them so
I know that's a very dark film but we
did want to bring a little bit of light
to the whole thing because
throughout our lives we only saw one
side which was actually quite negative
but I think that the film shows even
with some you know a terrible atrocity
that's there you know there is a there
is still humanity you can sort of still
see it there and I think that was
important for us because we you know we
experienced it firsthand ourselves at
the time well yeah I mean anybody from
the UK and Ireland remembers the shorter
they felt when when they hear the name
James Bulger mentioned is probably not
so much here but maybe every country has
one but I so I grew up hearing about
this case could never understand how two
ten-year-old boys could kill a toddler
but I was always told that it was
because they were evil just simply evil
born evil and and that's still the
popular opinion at the moment and I
understand it because when it happened
people just couldn't cope with the idea
that these were two ten-year-old boys
that had done it and the only way they
could make sense of it was if they were
evil and now that's become public
opinion and so ingrained in people's
minds they've been hearing it for 26
years in the tabloids so much so that
anybody who suggests an alternate reason
or or tries to understand oh these boys
they get criticized for it a nun
attacked and as a result its stifle
debate on the whole thing at the whole
issue you can't even talk about it and
so I wanted to make it because I think
there needs to be an informed public
debate on the circumstances which led to
this crime I think detainment is it
doesn't necessarily have all the answers
but it does allow people to ask the
right questions in Britain as some of
you may know a detainment has has in
particular caused a real uproar because
of the visceral nosov this this horrible
story all right we don't have too much
time left I'm going to ask for quick
answers on one last question we'll start
down the end
with with guy and Jamie
question is what do you like most about
your film the director the producer was
amazing with me especially after this
after the shooting day just know III you
know it's you
Wow it's a freaky question what can I
say my favorite sure sure so when we
cast a little the little kid as sort of
the lead got a little kid in it we were
skyping with him and his mom sent me a
video of his school they had for school
they had to pick their favorite animal
and he chose a snake and he had to do a
whole presentation about the snake and
so when we were shooting guy said hey
Jackson why don't you just while we're
rolling do your dear snake you know
pitch why snake sir and that ended up in
the film and sort of was a metaphor and
I loved how you know guy just sort of
really was able to transfer that from
real life and put it into the film in it
stayed
that's a brilliant answer thank you Mary
Ann and Mary Ellen favorite part of your
film I think the connection between the
two actresses the fact that the film is
about love but ageless it's you know
love can be between a man and women two
men two women and dependent no doesn't
the mad eh doesn't matter so I think
that that really shows through that and
the bath scene I think is the fact that
we you see a woman's body aging that is
something that's rarely seen and it's
shown with sensuality yeah that's what I
would say as well as it brings it's it's
it's it's two female characters that are
not stereotyped this dairy it's stereo
to your stereotypical characters that
you see in in films these days they're
not sex symbols they're not angry
mothers they're not crazy ex-girlfriends
they're just women and of you know an
eight
old woman and a 40 year old woman so
that's what I love the most
very good and Jeremy and Maria Garcia
your your what do you like most about
your film I have to say I think it's the
experience and the way that like it's so
much work but there's so many people
involve and it's crazy how it builds
such a strong relationship when you're
there and I also just want to
acknowledge that here we have also the
other producer of the film
evarin wizard who's there who's an
amazing man and producer and yeah I feel
like making movie kind of remember us
what is it to create something together
and I think this bond is really
particular and in fove there was so many
challenges and that all the team works
so in with us that was kind of a crazy
beautiful part of the experience I agree
and I will add on this that the way the
shoot ended was so beautiful because
we're actually shooting the last shot of
the film which is the boy crying and the
Fox at the same time at sunset we were
running late and Felix was just so good
like and people actually crying on set
of looking at him doing his performance
and and then we wrapped the shoot and
then we take her that the crew picture
and then certainly there's fireworks we
don't know where the pub where they came
from but they explode in this guy and it
was just magical
very good and lastly Vincent and Darren
what do you like most about your film
for me I think it's the performances of
the two boys or just
and to to actually be there on set when
they when they were performing it was
like real life it really was it was I've
never experienced anything like it like
it was incredible absolutely yeah it's
gonna be the performances of those boys
they are two incredibly talented child
actors eli sylvan and leon hughes and I
mean it that was probably the biggest
challenge of the film you know to find
these two boys that could convincingly
play those roles and and there's so many
these challenging emotional scenes and
they all had to ring true because if
they didn't I mean the film would have
just been a disaster so I mean a lot of
us you know is down to those two boys I
think and yeah so and I was great
working with Miss well you know eli
hadn't even acted so yeah there were
probably two of the most challenging
roles I think for child actors to play
and and it was great to be able to give
them this opportunity to to reach their
potential and to do that excellent III
could do this for another hour but we're
not gonna I want to thank our film
makers and congratulate you and thank
our audience for being here